[Music]
all right as you can see we are at the
Hannity big board tonight for a very
special reason tonight you see all this
all this year we're going to untangle
the giant web of Clinton scandals and
corruption it's unlike anything we have
ever done on the show before it's coming
up in just a few minutes but first the
Attorney General Jeff Sessions he
appeared to downplay the idea of
appointing a special counsel to
investigate the corrupt uranium one deal
and the pay-to-play Clinton Foundation
issue however sources are telling me
tonight sessions may in fact not be
revealing all of his cards now I can
tell you this tonight from what I am
hearing investigations may already be
underway and things apparently are
moving very quickly now keep that in
mind while you listen to this exchange
between Ohio Congressman Jim Jordan and
the Attorney General Jeff Sessions about
appointing a special counsel what's this
what's it going to take if all that not
to mention the dossier information
what's it going to take to actually get
a special counsel it would take a
factual basis that meets the standards
of the appointment of a special is that
is that analysis going on right now well
that's in the manual of the apartment of
Justice about what's required we've only
had two the first one was the Waco Janet
Reno senator Danforth who took over that
investigation as special counsel and mr.
Muller each of those a pretty special
factual situation yes at this and we
will use the proper standards and that's
what only thing I can tell you mr.
Jordan well I appreciate you can have
your idea but sometimes we have to study
what the facts are and to evaluate
whether it meets the standard well all
right now the Department of Justice has
since put out a statement tonight to
further explain Attorney General Jeff
Sessions comments it says quote the
Attorney General was clarifying the
legal basis for appointing a special
counsel not passing judgment on whether
it applied in any specific investigation
now that statement and sessions
testimony today is crucial in all of
this now sessions is explaining that
just because the special counsel has not
been appointed that does not mean that
it won't have
and that the threshold for one won't
eventually be met now look we've been
exposing these massive Clinton scandals
and frankly I believe crimes on this
show for over a year
yes it's frustrating people are getting
impatient I totally understand why
Congressman Jim Jordan was pressing and
demanding answers to important questions
we all want the truth there needs to be
an investigation because we know laws
were broken we know crimes were
committed the evidence is overwhelming
it's incontrovertible now with all that
said things are happening that we can't
reveal all the information tonight but
here's what I can tell you if you listen
very closely to sessions today he is
suggesting that it would take quote a
factual basis that meets the standards
of a special counsel in order for the
DOJ to make that type of appointment
those words I can assure you were
carefully crafted now sources told me
earlier this month and we reported it
right here in this show that sessions
has not hear me has not recused himself
in the uranium one scandal and if
there's an ongoing investigation
sessions isn't going to can't reveal all
that in an open setting in front of
Congress now we're going to have a lot
more to say about these things in coming
days now congressman Ron De Santis he
also had a very interesting exchange
with the Attorney General today watch
this in the past as did the FBI or DOJ
inform either President Obama Secretary
Clinton any cabinet secretary that it
had uncovered evidence that Rossi Tom's
main US executive that vadym nakeeran
was engaged in bribery kickbacks and
money laundering before the Obama
administration approved the uranium one
sale in 2010 it is it that the mcaren
matter the matter that was prosecuted in
Maryland 90/14 but there was an
informant in 2009/2010 the FBI had
evidence of bribery kickbacks and money
laundering was that information conveyed
to any of the relative people on the
city s board the Clinton there cabinet
secretaries or was it given to the
president
the way I understand that matter is that
the case in which mr. Mikan was
convicted was not connected to the
cepheus problem that occurred two to
three years before all that should sound
very familiar because it is exactly what
the facts are what we've been telling
you on the show for months that Vladimir
Putin and his agents they orchestrated a
bribery kickback money laundering
racketeering scheme all in an attempt to
get a foothold in America's uranium
market now this of course was all going
on while Hillary Clinton and the Obama
administration were signing off on that
corrupt uranium one deal yet nobody did
anything to stop Putin and his plan now
there's so much important information
that we need to explain tonight and
we're gonna untangle this web of Clinton
corruption and show you how all of it is
connected all right let's start right up
here with the uranium one scandal at the
very center of this we have of course Oh
Hillary Clinton now in 2010 Clinton was
serving as a Secretary of State one of
our responsibilities was as the head of
the department's of state to serve on a
committee of foreign investment in the
United States it's known as Sophia's now
it was made up of nine officials from
different departments in the federal
government they were tasked with
reviewing foreign investments in US
companies and resources one last point
here you see all of this now remember we
don't have enough uranium in this
country we have to import uranium now
another notable Obama official that was
serving on that board was the Attorney
General
that's Eric Holder and together along
with seven other Obama officials well on
this government board they approved the
sale of a company called uranium one to
a foreign nuclear energy company pay
close attention here watch all of this
I'm beginning to unfold now uranium one
was a Canadian based uranium mining
company and it controlled an estimated
20% of raw uranium in the United States
by the way we don't have enough we
import it in other words one-fifth of
America's supply of the foundational
material used to make nuclear weapons
and we import it because we need it and
company that Hillary Clinton Eric Holder
and other Obama officials allowed to buy
uranium ones for Raza Tom that's a
Russian state-run atomic energy
conglomerate that's controlled by
Vladimir Putin and the Russians you know
the bad actors the hostile regime now to
put this simply then Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton and others nine total
approved a Russian takeover of 20% of
America's uranium supply in 2010 now
it's all while Vladimir Putin was
becoming more and more hostile on the
world stage why would anyone let alone
members of our government think it's a
good idea to let Putin control 20% of
our uranium supplies when we don't have
enough it never made sense it still
doesn't make sense it's not like America
has a lot of uranium to begin with
guess what Hillary Clinton Eric Holder
if you look at all of this up here and
the rest of the Obama administration I
argue created a national security crisis
this is insanity and then in 2010 during
the very same time that the Iranian won
deal was being reviewed by the
government board former President Bill
Clinton he sought approval from his own
wife State Department to meet in Moscow
with high-ranking board members of this
group Raza Tom that controls all their
energy there the request was made while
Bill Clinton prepared to give a $500,000
paid speech in Moscow twice as usual
speaking fee the bank involved by the
way had a financial interest in all of
this uranium one and it was called
renaissance capital and they have links
to the Kremlin and it was actively
lobbying for the Russians to take over
uranium 1 now ultimately this Beach took
place but meeting with Rossi Tom never
happened
instead doe Clinton just sat down with
Vladimir Putin himself now the last
piece of this web of corruption is the
Clinton Foundation now between 2009 and
2013 the chairman of uranium 1 used this
family foundation to make millions of
dollars in donations to the Clinton
Foundation before and after Hillary
approved the sale the company to Putin
in Russia and that's not all all the
uranium 1 investors guess what they also
donated
millions of dollars to the Clinton
Foundation now where I come from that
sounds like a quid pro quo that's what
we call pay to play now look at all of
that you see that
okay that's only part of it now let's
turn to the second ongoing Clinton
scandal
now no matter how much Hillary Clinton
the flexin ignores this issue the
scandal surrounding a private server
will not go away because she broke the
law and she got away with it
this all started in 2008 private server
email account set up under the name of a
former Clinton aide in 2009 Hillary
Clinton becomes Secretary of State she
uses that personal email account to
conduct official State Department
business where she sent and received
top-secret special access program
classified information you're not
allowed to do that this came to light in
2015 after the House Select Committee on
Benghazi subpoenaed Hillary Clinton's
emails related to the Benghazi terror
attack following the subpoena an
employee a Platte River networks that's
that small mom-and-pop shop in a
bathroom tech company well they were
responsible for servicing Hillary
Clinton's private server and let's see
they deleted what over 30,000 emails
using something that's called bleach bit
it's like acid washing your harddrive
then once all of this was revealed and
because of concerns that Hillary may
have mishandled top-secret government
information the FBI actually opened a
criminal investigation find out what's
going on here
you're not allowed to do this the person
in charge of the investigation was then
FBI director James Comey see how this is
all beginning to come together here oh
pretty interesting now during the course
of the investigation the Attorney
General Loretta Lynch asked James Comey
hey don't call this an investigation
call it a matter Oh take the Clinton
talking points and call me willfully
complied then one week before James
Comey announced the FBI's decision on
whether or not to pursue charges against
Hillary Clinton and then the Attorney
General Loretta Lynch who you can see
right here and former President Bill
Clinton you can see right there they had
that meeting on the tarmac for a private
meeting lasting 40 minutes when pressed
about it Lynch said oh we were only
talking innocent small talk about golf
and our grandchildren and then
after a week of this meeting a week
after Comey announced the FBI would not
recommend charges for Hillary Clinton
even though he spent a good 13 and a
half minutes explaining how Clinton had
top-secret special access program
classified information stored on that
unsecured server that anyone could have
hacked and by the way we believe five
foreign intelligence agencies did and we
also since found out that the original
draft of commis announcement will
describe Clinton's actions as grossly
negligent okay that is the legal
standard but then after three drafts it
was changed to extremely careless they
didn't want to site with the actual law
set and we also know that Comey made his
decision not to recommend charges
against Clinton before he ever
interviewed the key witnesses in the
case including Clinton herself the fix
was clearly in and that's why all of
this here needs to be investigated look
how important look how this all begins
to tie together one common thread
Hillary Clinton now our third scandal
involves fusion GPS and the fake news
Russian propaganda anti-trump dossier
now of course at the very center of this
scandal there you go that's Hillary
Clinton again and during her failed run
for the White House
the Clinton campaign paid millions and
millions of dollars to a law firm it was
named Perkins Coie for legal fees
now the Clinton controlled DNC also paid
millions of dollars to this same very
law firm during that same period a
lawyer within the firm then employed a
consulting company you've heard about it
fusion gps which in turn utilized the
services of a former foreign spy
there's Christopher steal steal use the
current and former Russian government
sources to create the now infamous
totally discredited fake news Russian
lies propaganda misinformation dossier
that was all an attempt they paid for it
she paid for it
to influence you the American people and
the election and lie to you and
propagandize to you now prior to the
election the Stasi a was secretly
shopped around eventually ended up in
the hands of Senator John McCain
mccain passes the document to the FBI
director james comey
and now there are concerns that this
fake dossier was used as evidence in
order to justify a russia collusion
investigation into the Trump campaign in
other words was this dossier actually
used in FISA Court to get a warrant to
surveil the Trump campaign or an
opposition party this dossier was not
made fully available to the public until
BuzzFeed ended up publishing it On
January 10th of 2017 well after the
election well now we turn our focus see
this another one another troubling
scandal and questions that are raised
over a former Democratic IT staffer now
we begin this time with Florida
congresswoman debbie Wasserman Schultz
change-of-pace
one of Hillary Clinton's top allies in
the Democratic Party now she employed
and IT staff renamed in Ron a Juan now
on and several of his relatives all
right they all worked for congressional
Democrats as IT staffers for years and
they reportedly earned between two and
four million dollars all while having
access to house servers and earlier this
year all news broke of an investigation
into a Juan and his family they were
double billing hmm how did they do that
and stealing house equipment Democratic
lawmakers rightly fire Dhawan and his
relatives and he was denied access to
the house servers but as Fox News has
reported Debbie wasserman-schultz
she kept him on it her payroll then in
March of this year a Juan's wife and
their children flew to Pakistan where
Juan had been sending a lot of money and
finally a Juan was arrested in July at
Dulles Airport in Virginia he was trying
to board a flight to Pakistan and was
charged with bank fraud all while some
fear that he was responsible for
exposing House Democrats information
online now meanwhile Debbie
wasserman-schultz is defending her
decision to keep this guy on the payroll
despite the fact that he was under
investigation and only fired him after
his arrest and now in tonight's final if
you will
scandal we have more shocking evidence
when it comes she's back to Hillary
Clinton as it relates to the fix being
in
the Democratic Party is now in disarray
following revelations that Hillary
Clinton rigged and stole the 2016
primary now this scandal started all the
way back in 2015 when Hillary Clinton
declared her candidacy for president now
at the time one of Clinton's strongest
supporters was none other than
congresswoman debbie Wasserman Schultz
she was serving as the chair of the
Democratic National Committee Hillary
Clinton well she wanted nothing more to
be president but the socialist senator
from Vermont Bernie Sanders he was
standing in her way for Bernie right
the primary fight was closed and in July
of 2016 just days before the Democratic
National Convention WikiLeaks releases
thousands of emails allegedly hacked
from key DNC staff members those emails
they exposed how the DNC was working
against him the fix was in for her now
response to the DNC hacking well did
Wasserman Schultz and the DNC go to the
FBI to investigate alleged cyber attacks
no of course not why would they do that
instead they hired a law firm again
perkins coie sound familiar remember
them that's the same law firm from the
discredited fusion GPS anti-trump
dossier they're the ones that were
connected there and as you can imagine
people were outraged over what was
discovered in the leak in Wasserman
Schultz she had to step down on the eve
of the convention she was replaced by
Donna Brazile Donna Brazile just wrote a
book in that book Donna Brazile slammed
Wasserman Schultz as you can see here
and by saying that she let Clinton
headquarters in Brooklyn do whatever
they wanted they were running the DNC
she revealed that a secret contract
existed between the Clinton campaign
right here and at the NC and Brazil
exposed how Hillary Clinton in her
campaign had total control of the DNC's
finances strategy personnel decisions
budgeting data analytics and mailings
and for all of you who would have voted
for this man Bernie Sanders you were
cheated the DNC sold you out and Clinton
literally stole the primary election
look these are all massive scandals for
years we have been warning you about the
web of
option committed by the Clinton crime
family that they've gotten away with for
decades and now take a look at this it
shows the entire scale of the Clintons
willingness to do anything and
everything to gain power and wealth at
all costs look at this pretty amazing
there's so much to investigate